welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is an Adela Oh an assistant professor of
political science at Yale University
professor della OHS research interests
include causes and consequences of
redistribution effects of anti-poverty
programs on the political behavior of
recipients in developing countries
particularly Latin America and the use
of field experimental research methods
today we'll talk with Professor delao
about her recent research on the
politics of conditional cash transfers
welcome professor della thanks Marilyn
for the invitation let's talk a little
bit about your manuscript give us an
overview of it well my manuscript is
trying to answer two interrelated
questions the first has to do with the
proliferation of conditional cash
transfer programs so these are programs
that transfer money cash to poor
households and the transfers are
contingent on parents making investments
in their children's education and health
and as it turns out these problems have
been very popular in Latin America and
so the manuscript is trying to answer
under what conditions were going to see
countries adopting these programs with
the strict rules and we're going to see
them adopting these programs with loose
rules and so the second part of that of
the book is answering the question of
what are the consequences in terms of
political development of these countries
of adopting these programs okay
well it's mostly Latin America but a
minor street has one part that focuses
exclusively on Mexico Colombia and Peru
and then it was a large and study of all
Latin American countries okay and what
gave you the idea for this
well the idea for this book is started
when I was doing fieldwork in Mexico in
rural Mexico and they're talking to
women that were recipients of the
Mexican CCT program surprised me because
these women were very informed about
what this program was about so they
you exactly what were the requirements
to be in the program and how much money
they were getting and when they were
getting it and so that just makes me
think that this was really very
different from previous Clent allistic
type of programs where money would get
if people bought it for an incumbent and
and so then the question is why would a
party such as a PRI in Mexico that is
famous for having such a powerful
political machine would implement a
program that is so technical and
apolitical and so the question is once
you implemented what happens to these
women so would they still vote for the
incumbent and why would they vote for
the incumbent okay welcome we'll come
back to that in a minute
um tell us about your methodology how
did you do the research well the book
has many parts it's it's it's a it's a
complicated question in the sense that
it has different puzzles so to answer
part of the puzzles I used more
qualitative type of work like it leads
interviews and interviews with party
brokers archival work in Colombia Peru
and Mexico and then other parts of the
book require more quantitative work so I
use analysis of experimental work and
Largent studies okay let's let's go back
to your findings can you tell us perhaps
by country you know what your research
has found Mexico Peru Colombia well the
whole story is basically that the
consequences of these programs have very
much to do with domestic politics okay
so one of the obvious explanations for
why you see the proliferation would be
to say that it's international agencies
such as the World Bank that are big
sponsors of these programs and so that
would explain why countries adopt them
and the consequences but as it turns out
involvement of the World Bank can
explain the variation that we see in the
quality of the design of the program and
then how rigorous the implementation is
so so the first expansion is it has to
do with local politics with domestic
politics okay and now there are
countries like in Mexico for instance
where when these programs were adopted
first the president was uncertain as to
whether legislators from his own party
and from the opposition would approve
the budget for these programs okay and
so that led policymakers to include
provisions in operational rules that
would guarantee a very strict operation
of the program and as a consequence in
this type of countries like Mexico you
would not see enrollment following up
political business cycles that we just
see before so more people being rolled
right before elections we don't see that
anymore and also as a consequence we see
that local politics is really turned on
its head so here a a very lucrative coat
that I got from a party broker was that
what the program implementers didn't get
is that they made their life really
difficult for party brokers because now
they can't really decide who stays and
who is out of the program and they can
punish people sort of based on who vote
for them and with you and vote for them
so that just gives you a picture of what
happens in countries like Mexico now
there are other countries for instance
say Bolivia or at the beginning Peru
where the president didn't have that
uncertainty about how legislators would
react to that program and in that case
you see programs with less strict rules
you see more enrollment closer to
election time and you see that these
programs are sort of continuing this
catalystic linkages and the interesting
thing about Peru is that you see a
change over time so when the president
loses the majority in Congress you see
this program starting to get more rules
it's at there and the case of Colombia
sort of follows up the Peruvian case
where at the beginning it was looser and
then as competition increases
uncertainty increases and more rules are
applied to this program okay and did you
come across any difficulties or
surprises when you were doing the
research well let's see the big the big
surprise is that these programs have
been incredibly appealing to politicians
both from the left and the right so at
the beginning in in the Mexican case
this program was implemented under the
administration of Ernesto severe who's
now here at Yale yes and and and this
was a very Pro free market government
but then these programs were by with a
presidential election were for the first
time in seven decades appear I lost the
majority
I mean love the presidential seat by
then they had already lost a majority in
Congress and so it was very surprising
to see this particular type of cast run
for surviving such a huge political
transition and then in Brazil you see
the opposite case so you see you see
this the CCT is surviving arriving to a
left-wing government so with Lola's the
electoral victory and so the surprising
thing is that at first sight it has
nothing to do with politics because
parties from all different sides of the
ideological spectrum are actually
implementing these programs but then
when you look closer it turns out that
is a completely political story so I
guess the challenge was how to
undercover that story okay
and how did you undercover how did you
uncover it okay gets into place so one
of the things that I did was read over
all the debates in Congress and when the
budgets of these programs were being
this cost and there were comes across
very clearly is that there are some
places where legislators are very
worried about how these terms are going
to be implemented are there going to be
clamped allistic are they going to buy
boats for the incumbent opposition
parties of course on one side but on the
other hand and particularly in the
Mexican case legislators from the own PR
I didn't want this program because it
basically circumvented the whole
political machine of the PRI and so you
just start to see that political story
coming across very clearly now in the
Peruvian case it so it's it's also an
interesting example of how politics
starts to sort of show itself in the
getting the congressional debates to the
point that lays leaders were discussing
to change the name of the program which
originally so the program was the reason
I called something like Peru juntos
which was pretty similar to the name of
the coalition of the other president
okay and so so legislators didn't want
to have of course a name that was so
similar to the electoral coalition and
so I ended up calling the program juntos
okay so so sorry so yes so you see that
start doing that archival work leads to
thinking more about the domestic
politics and then of course the
challenge is proving
argument sure and so that is challenging
and so instead of directly proving what
legislators were thinking but the book
test is proving some of the implications
of the argument with a large end study
and and experimental work for different
countries okay and so so what are the
political consequences of conditional
cash transfers well the first thing to
note is that there's sort of two sets of
consequences okay so in places where the
programs are strictly implemented what
we see is that Clent ilysm is weakened
we don't see those electoral business
cycles that I was mentioning before on
the other hand you do see people voting
for the incumbent so it's sort of like a
sort of virtuous circle where you have
programs that target poverty in a
successful way according to what but we
know from development economists and on
the other hand it helps sort of create
this relationship between borders and
politicians that is different from
cantle ism but then on the other hand
you have what programs are not
implemented in a straight way you have
this linkages of Gentiles of being
solidified okay and have you seen have
you looked at the actual programs
themselves in terms of are they
benefiting you know the people who are
getting the the money basically
is there a variation between countries
in terms of the benefits of CCT do some
countries implement it better than
others yeah we certainly see a lot of
variation in in terms of the ultimate
effects of this program on the
well-being of the families that are
being targeted so it's a difficult
question to answer just because poverty
it's multi-dimensional and there is a
short-term effect and a long-term effect
that these programs are supposed to have
what we do know that it's in the
short-term for instance in the Mexican
case in the short term we do know that
girls stay low
at school particularly it helps them
make the transition from primary to
secondary school we know that for
instance the incidence of illnesses such
as diarrhea among babies decreases we
know for instance that the parents have
better health just because of the
transfers that these programs are making
have some positive externalities so we
know those little facts about the
short-term effects of these programs and
this is all based on a randomized study
that the Mexican government implemented
in the early stages of the
implementation of this program now we
also have some evidence for other
programs now the problem is that for the
programs that are not as strictly
implemented we don't have good
evaluations okay so what we don't know
is for instance what happens in
countries like Bolivia for instance that
has a very loose program so we don't
know what are the impacts of those
transfers on well being we could have
speculate that maybe they're not as
great as a program that is strictly
implemented but we don't have that
evidence yet okay and conclusions that
you reach in your manuscript well well I
guess the the bottom line of the
manuscript is that there is a way to
alleviate poverty so if there is a way
to alleviate poverty making this
transfer is compatible with democratic
habits so we in Latin America serve
scholars of Latin America tend to think
of transfers as a very Clent allistic
most of linkage between politicians and
citizens but what these these transfers
the CCT transfers are showing is that
there is a way of making this transfer
is compatible with borders expressing
their preferences participating in
elections and breaking these linkages of
clintonism so I guess that's the the
bottom line would be that they are ways
of making these two things compatible of
course there's always this other side
that this transfers of course can be
also manipulated we get into that second
a path that I described before okay
very good thank you so much for being
here with us today and sharing some of
your work thanks Marilyn for more
information about Professor della Oh and
her work please visit our website at
Yale edu backslash Macmillan report be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale